récurrent une fusillade impliquant des
jeunes qui ont tout juste atteint la
majorité mais les événements malheureux
comme celui-ci deviennent monnaie
courante ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui c'est
un problème de société c'est un enjeu de
société c'est ensemble qui va faire le
régler selon Statistique Canada 38% des
auteurs présumés de crimes commis avec
une arme à feu en 2020 était des hommes
de 12 à 24 ans pourquoi se trouve-t-il
vers la violence armée ça commence à la
maison l'éducation cette intervenant
cite l'APA du gain associé à la
criminalité et au commerce interlope
mais aussi un contexte socio-économique
défavorable à Toronto les données
montrent que les tireurs sont de plus en
plus jeunes certains ayant même moins de
15 ans au Québec comme en Ontario il y a
ceux associés aux gang de rue puis ceux
sans histoire dans les deux cas ça remis
est souvent un moyen de se défendre
pas beaucoup de jeunes à des jeunes qui
sont oui dans les dernières années
plusieurs épisodes de coups de feu de
Siri en plein jour ont suscité
l'indignation parfois près de lieux
publics faisant des victimes
collatérales comme s'il y avait un
sentiment d'impunité et d'insouciance
chez les jeunes habituellement
les jeunes qui sont dans les gangs n'ont
pas vraiment ne sont pas vraiment
disons regardant sur le lieu ils vont là
où sont les cibles et puis il y a la
problématique des réseaux sociaux ou les
jeunes scintimides et s'affichent avec
des armes à feu des plateformes ou les
autorités doivent s'investir davantage
c'est l'espace qui est le moins
surveillé
par les forces de police entre la masse
de choses qui se passent et le peu de
ressources qu'ils ont par rapport à ça
c'est sûr qu'ils sont pas capables de
tout voir pour Michael Farcas la
prévention par le sport et la culture
pour que les jeunes puissent développer
des intérêts et un sentiment
d'appartenance ici aimer le mieux
Radio-Canada Montréal